LOT OF THIS HOCKEY CLUB, THEY
ARE HARD WORKING TEAM.
PENGUINS, NUMBER 59, GUENTZEL
SMASHED IN BY TOROPCHENKO.
HIT
SAAD IS THE COULD GET TO
THAT PUCK.
>> John: HERE IS A DRIVE
LIKE HUSSO HAD A GOOD BEAT ONTH.
THE BLUES KRUG.
STEERED AROUND THE GLOBE. BY BU.
OF MIKKOLA UP ON THIS SIDE, IVAN
BARBASHEV.
>> Darren: ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU
HAVE BSKATERS, MATHESON IS.
MARINO PLAYS IN ON.
BLUES DON'T CLEAR IT AGAIN.
BOY, BARBASHEV.
NOW CROSBY AND FRONT.
MARINO LEFT IT WIDE AND T T THAA
FABULOUS MOVEMENT.
A RIGHTY THE PENGUINS BK, NUMBER
ONE ON THE ROAD IN THE HEMMED IN
AND THE DEFENSIVE ZONE.
WE'LL SEE IF SUNDQVIST CAN
>> Darren: GOOD FACE-OFF WIN
BY THE FORMER PENGUINS ON QUEST.
T
THE REFEREE, THINKING THERE
SHOULD HAVE BEEN A CALL,
LETANG.
>> John: HERE IS
SCHENN.L.
>> John: BLUES WIN
SHOVELED IN BY SCHENN WITH THREE
SOMEWHERE AROUND THEHE
NOW HEADS SOUTH.
THE BLUES MAKING A CHANGE F F W.
THE PENGUINS COME BACK.
A PASS WHO THE ICE AND HE GETS
THE PASS UNDER DRIVE THAT JUST
GOES YEAR.
THEY
IN FRONT FOR FAULK, BLOCKEDED
NECESSARILY HIGH, BUT JUST ABOUT
THEFOR THE GOAL.
LOOK AT THE POSITIONING.
YES, IT JUST GLANCES OFF THE T E
STICK, YOU CAN FIRE AT AEY HAVER
SEEN BEFORE.
THAT ALSO DOES.
TRYING TO BE THE